[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de cultura de
france 24 el multipremiado director
guillermo del toro está de vuelta con el
callejón de las almas perdidas un
macabro cuento de hadas que sigue los
pasos de un espiritista con mucha labia
en su camino hasta la decadencia el
cineasta mexicano se apropió el material
de una película de cine negro de
1947 el charlatán de golding adaptada a
su es de un libro homónimo en esta
versión los brillantes actores bradley
cooper kate blanchett y toni collette
para nombrar sólo algunos nos llevan a
la época de los freak shows donde los
falsos monstruos se mezclan con el
encanto de las riquezas y el espiritismo
estos temas no son revolucionarios pero
la película consigue sumergirnos durante
dos horas y media gracias a sus
fabulosos decorados y su atmósfera
mística tan lograda un rico universo
visual para saborear en la gran pantalla
cuando james
este
orden
bueno
de acá para decir no entro en décadas
son agua
[Música]
volver
y si memphis
[Música]
lejos de los trucos y estafas del
callejón de las almas perdidas en suecia
del festival the thing the ghost vogue
ofreció a sus espectadores una verdadera
experiencia ver tres películas bajo
hipnosis colectiva reto intensificar la
experiencia de inmersión en la sala de
cine que ya se comparaba a menudo en sus
primeros años con la hipnosis una
sumisión mental consciente en la
frontera entre el sueño y la vigilia
concentrarse mejor sentir más los
colores los sonidos y las texturas los
comentarios del público fueron bastante
positivos
ah
mientras en suecia quieren profundizar
las sensaciones físicas del público se
abre paso al arte digital en venezuela
los toques no fungibles o energía es
decir las obras digitales únicas que se
venden con cripto monedas se han
convertido en una opción viable para
coleccionistas que les guardan su dinero
en cripto activos el arte venezolano se
encontraba de capa baja por la crisis
económica del país ahora con los ene efe
los artistas venezolanos encontraron una
importante fuente de ingresos como nos
cuenta nuestra corresponsal daniela
zambrano
no sé
la arepa el principal plato tradicional
de venezuela fue inmortalizado en una
colección de 50 toques no fungibles
estas piezas del joven artista óscar
olivares de 25 años de edad se vendieron
en menos de 12 horas y le dejó grandes
ganancias menos de 24 horas se habían
vendido más obras que en los últimos dos
meses con esa con esta colección de nfc
y te puedo decir que esta colección en
individual fue más exitosa en cuanto a
ventas que cualquier exposición
presencial difícil que haya tenido y no
porque no hayan sido exitosas porque lo
fueron sino que esto fue algo realmente
increíble el cierre de museos y galerías
en medio de la pandemia agravó la
difícil situación de los artistas en una
nación que atraviesa desde hace años una
grave crisis económica pero la toca
iniciación del arte digital llegó para
reactivar el mercado con nuevos
coleccionistas dispuestos a invertir en
el cripto arte con sello venezolano la
propuesta en la empresa en la que me
encuentro hoy en día es precisamente ir
hacia una nueva normalidad verdad y
adoptar todos todas las herramientas las
buenas prácticas del campo de lo
tradicional del mundo de la para
llevarlo al metaverso eva cortés
administradora de profesión y artista de
oficio también decidió incursionar en
los ene efe en medio de la pandemia
ahora son su principal fuente de
ingresos en un país donde el sueldo
mínimo no supera los tres dólares su
hija de seis años también ha logrado
utilizar obras de arte en diciembre del
año 2020 fue de navidad ella dibujo un
niño jesús' paisana acrílico y yo le
agregué la animación de los ojos para su
primera obra y fueron días ediciones que
se vendieron con eso puedo comprarle una
de sus manecitas buenas un regalo de
navidad el auge de los n ft ha impulsado
al arte venezolano que se encontraba
deprimido además ha dado la oportunidad
a talentosos artistas desconocidos de
competir en igualdad de condiciones con
los artistas tradicionales en el espacio
de la web 3.0 en la actualidad venezuela
se ubica en el top 10 de países que más
adquieren arte digital coleccionable
el internet con su difusión sin
fronteras con vio las carreras de estos
artistas venezolanos al igual que
plataformas como youtube cambiaron el
impacto de artistas musicales como la
brasileña anita y sus casi seis mil
millones de vistas acumuladas con sus
canciones el suceso de la superestrella
tiene mucho que ver con su versatilidad
anita empezó haciendo baile funk en
portugués logró instalarse en la escena
de reggaeton tras aprender a cantar en
español y ahora está conquistando al
mundo del electropop como demuestra su
última canción boys don't cry donde
pregunta quién dijo que los chicos no
lloran
[Música]
amigos
sí sí
puntos lectura
los raperos franceses y si yo voy
también nos muestran esta semana los
beneficios de hacer propuestas un poco
diferentes dos artistas que se están
imponiendo en el panorama de era rap
francés y con su primera colaboración
rotterdam ofrecen un tema totalmente
cantaron y más melódico de lo habitual
[Música]
en un guiño a la can la copa africana de
fútbol que finaliza el domingo 6 de
febrero nos despedimos con una canción
de en honor a este deporte va álbum dog
el balón de oro de las estrellas
nigerianas de la música afro bernabéu y
whisky de muchas gracias y cuídense
[Música]